hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
after distinguishing four main sources
of our moral duties and of everything
that is good in the virtues Cicero in
Chapter six of book one of on duties is
going to talk about what we can call the
first source of the right the first
source of the morally good and that is
wisdom wisdom is a virtue and Cicero
uses two different words here Sapientia
which we generally translate just as
wisdom and prudence iya which sometimes
we translate as practical wisdom or
prudence which is a cognate with it both
of them are really covering about the
same ground as far as the Stoics are
concerned and this is a text of stoic
ethics where he's taking Penn 80s as
ethics and presenting it to us now
Cicero thinks that part of why wisdom is
something that we human beings need is
because it fulfills our our nature and
our nature is that of a rational being
not just of any old animal that wants to
you know seek out its own benefit and
and reproduce itself and perhaps take
care of its children but we have
something you might say higher and
deeper motivating us something that we
really cannot escape from and that is
this this innate desire which he says
both draws us and leads us to seek and
appreciate truth through knowing it
through cognition the way that it runs
in in the Latin is here we go that it
consists in the Koch ditsy own a theory
the the cognition of truth getting to
know how things really are
Cicero thinks and this is a typical
stoic view that that all of us
our human nature have this this desire
within us and it can take many forms
some people want to know some things but
not not they're not very interested in
other things you know some people get
mixed up about what knowing is we'll
talk about that in just a moment but in
general what we can say is that we view
truth as a good we're actually the only
animal that gets concerned about whether
it's got things right or wrong you know
we're the only ones who check our work
you could say we're the only ones who
ask hey am i right about this to to
somebody else
we also view error or or getting things
wrong or ignorant as an evil as
something bad for us so if we find out
that we were fundamentally in the dark
about some matter we regard that as a
bad thing if we find out that we were
wrong we believed something to be false
that was actually true or something to
be true that was actually false we
consider that to be something bad for us
not just bad in sort of a evolutionary
way not just bad in a doesn't contribute
to our life going well kind of way
bad morally we view things that way this
is part of what it means according to
Cicero to be a human being it's really
inescapable so he goes on and he says
we're all attracted and drawn to a zeal
for learning and knowing and we also
think that it's something good to excel
in this it's not just good to achieve
it's good to keep on achieving if a
little bit of knowledge is good a lot of
knowledge is even better if knowing one
thing is good knowing a whole bunch of
things and how they're connected with
each other is even better that's the way
Cicero conceives of human beings
existing and this is a typical again
stoic view on human nature
we are rational beings and that is part
of what makes us the sort of animals
that we are he also picks out two errors
and literally you know the word for the
this is Vitti's vices two vices to avoid
what our vices vices are the opposite of
virtue so if you know wisdom is the
virtue that that leads us to desire and
to know truth and to genuinely be wise
means to know a lot of truth and to seek
a lot of truth and the value truth then
vices would be the opposite of that and
Cicero talks about here two main ways in
which people get things fundamentally
wrong one of these has to do with
treating things that are not known as if
they are known this is a very common
thing for people to do this is for
Cicero as well as for the Stoics a form
of foolishness a form of the opposite of
wisdom treating things that are unknown
as if we actually know what they are
jumping to conclusions we often talk
about making assumptions
the Stoics thought that when it comes to
things that we don't really know about
we ought to suspend our belief in them
we ought to investigate but we also
ought to be careful about it so you know
for example somebody says something mean
to me did he mean it I don't really know
I shouldn't jump to the conclusion that
he did or maybe he wasn't talking to me
or maybe he's actually having a bad day
and he just slipped up rather than
having it in for me
we shouldn't make all these assumptions
right
similarly we think about the Internet
right before we spread a news story
perhaps we should check it out ourselves
at least see what source it's coming
from if it's coming from something
that's fake news it's probably
foolishness for us to just click and
share it with somebody
we should also beware of things that fit
our biases
that lead us into thinking yeah I know
that you know we see a story about
somebody from the opposite end of the
political spectrum we already know that
they're bad people
so we don't need to check it out and see
whether it's all you know made-up stuff
let's just share it let's just believe
in it
well if that's that's actually a vice
that's an error according to Cicero
interestingly the other error that he
picks out has less to do with that sort
of getting things wrong and more to do
with a priority
Cicero talks about devoting too much
time too much effort too much of our
resources to matters that are any has
three things here he says obscure that
is hard to you know fathom unclear
difficult and unnecessary there could be
some things that are obscure and
difficult that are really necessary for
us to know you know it's difficult
sometimes to figure out where people
stand in terms of whether they love us
or don't love us it's obscure as well
but you know before you get married to
somebody you probably want to know that
so that's pretty necessary right unless
you think marriage doesn't need that
sort of knowledge right but there's a
lot of things where they're really not
necessary and they tend to be obscure
and difficult maybe we don't recognize
that they are so but they are and if
we're spending all of our time on that
we're not learning other truths and
we're not doing things with those other
truths that we should be in fact using
so Cicero will say that here we go
devoting too much time in industry and
too much deep study to matters that are
that are like this right then he goes on
and he says if we do avoid these errors
what we're going to discover is that the
efforts that we put in and this is part
of what wisdom is wisdom involves
work wisdom involves you know efforts to
to find out information to correlate the
information to make sense of it to sift
which is actually true which isn't and
then to apply it
he says if these errors are avoided all
the labor and pains expended on problems
that are worthwhile subjects one
translation is morally right but
worthwhile subjects in rebus
hone estas OH&S dis rather in the things
that are worth actually knowing he says
if if that's the case then the solving
will this will be fully rewarded and so
he gives examples or he says Gaius the
pill kiyose the field of astronomy
mathematics Sextus Pompey dialectics
many civil law even more and he says all
these professions are occupied with the
search after truth the study of
philosophy should be concerned with the
truth the study of the law oftentimes
it's not but it should be concerned with
truth studied political science should
be concerned with truth biology
astronomy and go down the line all of
these things should be concerned with
truth even things that we don't normally
think of in terms of truth social work
right should be concerned with truth
marketing should be concerned in some
degree with truth if not it's probably
concerns lies and it might be a form of
folly and we can go on and on and on
with many examples Cicero stresses two
other things he says the praise of
virtue the louse is praise or glory is
another way to translate it is in
actions in octaves right so when we
really have virtue even the virtue
that's concerned with intellectual
things it should culminate in some sort
of actions the knowledge should not just
be sitting there doing nothing it's
another reason we want to avoid devoting
too much attention to things that really
don't have any payoff he says that study
that draws us away from the act of life
is also drawing us away from our
is drawing us away from virtue it's not
really going to be wisdom this is a
really radical move on on Cicero's part
because most previous philosophers
including many people who he holds quite
dear like Plato like Aristotle said that
the contemplative life the theoretical
life the BIOS theoretical is the one
that is concerned not with acting not
doing things but just with understanding
say the universe was a better life was
more valuable
Cicero does not think that's the case
Cicero thinks that the life of virtue
including the virtue of wisdom has to be
a life that takes the form of activity
and a little bit later on he will say
that philosophers might actually be
doing the wrong thing by devoting
themselves to exclusively to purely
theoretical problems we might say
similar things about many other people
in our own time so he finishes up this
by saying all of our thoughts and mental
activity will be devoted either to
planning for things that are worthwhile
that are morally right and conduced to a
good and happy life right things that
are worth knowing things that conduce to
well living flourishing not just for
ourselves but also for those were
connected with or with the pursuits of
science and learning scantier
cognate cognate to onus of attribute
order right and so he acknowledges some
legitimacy to learning things for their
own sake he says look in your downtime
that's what you can do and that that's
actually what Cicero himself did but the
learning that you're doing should be
oriented sooner or later to doing
something with that learning so that is
sort of an overview of what Cicero
portrays as wisdom the first source of
the morally right the worthwhile the
good in his book on duties
you